last week we heard about an especially
loathsome group of people uh members of
a profession that shouldn't exist like
abortionists and prostitutes perhaps
ranked right in between those two on the
evil scale this is a group called
sensitivity readers and the group first
made it onto my radar and the radar of
lots of other people afterwards
announced that one of my fellow beloved
children's authors Roald Dahl was
enduring from the grave the humiliation
of having his work posthumously
Rewritten to remove and change quote
insensitive language the people that um
dolls publisher had put in charge of
this task were called sensitivity
readers whose only job is to read and be
sensitive now not sensitive to the
author's Legacy or intentions not
sensitive to what sort of language is
most descriptive or interesting not
sensitive to the Integrity of the work
that they're butchering not sensitive to
any of that but sensitive especially and
only to the rules of wokism as it
happens after a backlash against this PC
Hatchet job of a great and prolific
writer the publisher announced that they
announced later uh last week that the
unchanged and unmolested texts would now
still be available to purchase so they
will offer the sensitive version
um and then also the insensitive
original version that now both will be
on sale you can choose it's supposed to
make everything better but it only
manages to make the whole situation even
more grotesque and gratuitous in a lot
of ways because suddenly we're treating
The Works of recently deceased modern
authors as though their ancient
manuscripts in a foreign language
multiple versions multiple
interpretations multiple translations
are all offered you know the the Bible
has the the kgv KJV and the NIV and
dozens of other English translations
well Roald Dahl will soon have the
original the woke the Uber woke the
woker then woke
and then another version where every
single book is just a picture of a trans
guy beating a republican over the head
with a pride flag
but the scourge of these sensitivity
reader stretches far beyond rolled dull
his case is but the tip of a
purple-haired Iceberg and next uh inline
is Ian Fleming he's the creator of
course of James Bond next in line to
suffer the literary equivalent of corpse
desecration the Eric post reports this
Ian Fleming's James Bond books have been
Rewritten with modern audiences in mind
with so-called sensitivity experts
removing a number of racial references
ahead of 007's 70th Anniversary this
spring all of Fleming's Thrillers from
Casino Royale to Octopussy will be
re-released this spring after Ian
Fleming Publications the company that
owns the literary rights to Fleming's
work commissioned a review by
sensitivity readers now we should step
to the side here for a moment to quibble
uh just briefly with the way that the
post has phrased this because these
books are not being Rewritten with
modern audiences in mind I'm a member of
the modern audience and I have no
interest in Reading anything that's been
force-fed through a corporate d AI
seminar filter in fact as the backlash
against this kind of blasphemy shows
many members of the modern audience do
not want this no these books are being
Rewritten with a very narrow audience in
mind this is specifically being done to
appease the sorts of people who would
show up at a pride parade or attend a
drag brunch or you know who the sort of
people who would see a rope hanging from
a tree for a tire swing at the park and
then go to Twitter and claim that it was
a noose like those people specifically
is is is who's being uh targeted here
the particular neuroses of those sorts
of people are being catered to so don't
put this on the modern audience at large
put it on them be clear
back to the post it says the new version
of the classic novels will include a
disclaimer that reads quote
the book was written at a time when
terms and attitudes that might be
considered offensive by modern readers
were commonplace a number of updates
have been made to this Edition while
keeping as close as possible to the
original text and period in which it was
set
well no it's not as close as possible I
mean this is like if I made a delicious
batch of pancakes for breakfast then you
took my pancakes and tossed them in the
garbage and served up some frozen Eggos
that you didn't even bother to toast and
then said well these are as close as
possible to your pancakes no they aren't
the closest thing to my pancakes are my
actual pancakes that you threw in the
trash you can't claim that you're trying
your best to preserve the spirit of my
pancakes when you had them and you chose
to discard them
maybe getting a little sidetracked with
this analogy get my point a little more
from the post it says in some cases
racial descriptors and mentions of the
n-word have been completely scrubbed
from the text in the novel Dr No
criminals escaping from Bond are now
going to be referred to as gangsters and
the race of a doctor an immigration
officer now goes unmentioned the
ethnicity of a bar man in the in
Thunderball is also emitted as is the
race of a butler in Quantum of Solace
and many other similar additions and
omissions have been made as well but
this is not just happening to Ian
Fleming and Roald Dahl as mentioned
there is a burgeoning industry of
sensitivity readers in in publishing now
they are cancerous tumors spreading as
rapidly as di Consultants did a few
years before them their only job is to
deface the work of writers both dead and
alive
and if I were to conduct a psychological
profile of these creeps I could say with
near certainty that they are almost all
people who couldn't hack it as authors
themselves like they wanted to be
authors and they couldn't do it because
they're not good writers and so now they
spend their time bastardizing the work
of authors who are doing what they could
never do
they say that those who can't do teach
well we might also say that those who
can't write become now sensitivity
readers recently the website reason uh
called attention to this parasitic
infestation in the publishing industry
um in their report after telling the
anecdotal story of a very much still
alive writer who had his manuscript
disemboweled and dismembered by a team
of sensitivity readers uh hired by his
publisher in fact what we're told is
that he was uh he had written a story
and it featured prominently black
characters and the the Publishers had
assumed that he was a black author
himself and then it turns out that
although he's a racial minority they
found out well he's not actually black
and that changed everything the story
that they liked they realized this story
is now problematic because you're not
the right racial category to write it
and that's when they brought in the
sensitivity readers to change everything
to get in line with their sensitivities
uh so we're told that story then we're
told this known as sensitivity readers
or sometimes authenticity readers these
Consultants are a growing part of
publishing hire to correct
pre-publication or as we know sometimes
post-publication missteps of authors who
don't share the same traits or lived
experience to use a favored buzzword as
their characters the sensitivity readers
possible areas of expertise are as
varied as human existence itself one
representative consultancy boasts a list
of experts in the usual racial ethnical
ethnic and religious categories but also
in such areas as agoraphobia Midwestern
physical disability arms and legs
specifically that kind of disability and
gamer geek another one lists individual
readers with intersectional
qualifications depending on the content
of your novel you might hire a white
lesbian with generalized anxiety
disorder or a bisexual gender fluid
light-skinned Brown uh Mexican with a
self-diagnosis of autism every medical
condition every trauma every form of
Oppression sensitivity readers will
cover it all
now as always
um the thing that jumps out of you about
these woke speech police it's not their
sensitivity I mean they actually aren't
sensitive at all you have to be a
soulless psychopath to impose your own
ideological fixations onto someone
else's work whether living or dead
but rather what jumps out at you then is
there is there arrogance their unbridled
ego I mean just think about this these
people will tell an author
what would be most authentic for the
fictional characters that he created
but there's of course only one person on
Earth who can speak with final Authority
about the characters an author creates
and that is the author if I write a
story about an agoraphobic black lesbian
and I might just do that now just to
spite these people literally whatever I
have that black lesbian say or do is
authentic and correct because she's my
character it doesn't make any sense for
for you to say well no that character
doesn't say that or do that what are you
talking about this comes from my mind
these are my characters so she's gonna
do whatever I tell her to do
she might not ring true to your
experiences but I didn't write about
your experiences
okay not everything in the world is
about you I wrote about the experiences
of this Phantom person I made up
whatever I say happened to her whatever
I say she did or said that's it that's
the final and absolute word you can't
come along after the fact and change it
on the basis that I should have written
something different first of all who are
you to say what I should have written
second even if I even if it makes sense
to say well you should have written
something different
I didn't though okay I didn't happen to
write whatever you think I should have
written I happened to write what I wrote
uh Roald Dahl Ian Fleming you can say
well they should have he he and Fleming
should have phrased it differently in
this book
uh he didn't though so that's what he
actually wrote is what you have there
you might not like it it might upset you
it makes your tummy hurt but that's what
he wrote
changing it later especially after the
author is dead is a lie it's another
attempt to bend the world
um even now the fictional world to the
egocentric whims of this insufferable
minority of cry bully vultures
now not to rehash the debates the
debates of of last week
but I need to also mention that this is
yet another reason why I choose a harsh
and Unapologetic approach uh when I'm
dealing with the woke mob and all of its
various tentacles okay
this is why it's another one of the
reasons why I approach things personally
the way that I do these are people who
have come to believe largely because
they've been told
that they have the right to have their
own particular sensitivities and
perceptions and desires and Hang-Ups and
fetishes constantly affirmed by everyone
and everything everywhere all the time
even now this right extends to books
written by authors who are dead
even that must was is uh is caught up in
his Dragnet
of narcissism
everything and everyone must affirm and
nothing must ever challenge nothing must
ever contradict they must never run into
any immovable objects they must never
encounter any wall that doesn't topple
over the moment they lightly push
against it
this is what they're told
awoke mob it's how they live it's what
they demand of the world
and I believe the only solution the only
antidote the only way out of this is to
tell them no and to say it loud and to
say it often and to say it without
apology these people need to be
contradicted they need to be rebuked
they need even to be mocked to have
their feelings dismissed to have their
sensitivities utterly disrespected and
disregarded they need this
they need it it is a need it's like the
rest of us need water and air and they
need that too but they also need this
it's their only hope of ever becoming
good productive human beings their only
hope and it is society's Only Hope of
ever escaping the grasp of these whiny
unbearable micromanaging jerks
in fact we should upset them just for
the sake of it
trolling these tyrants is a virtue it is
a virtuous act because it is an act of
rebellion against disorder Rebellion
against moral confusion and intellectual
rot
it is in other words a good and virtuous
thing
good and virtuous to say to these people
especially the sensitivity readers kiss
my ass
and also you're canceled no that's not
the right segment for that but it just
felt right to say at some point
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]